just a couple of quick things john hein
described his uh
usual routine at the mcdonald's
drive-through i thought that was
particularly entertaining
i do not pull away until i open the bag
inspect the burger make sure that
there's no cheese on it
and then i go and if there is cheese on
it i hand it right back
john also told us that he would love to
run a mcdonald's one day
that led to gary revealing on the
wrap-up show that he was very very close
to opening a vinyl pop-up store in
connecticut
what's going to be in the vinyl pop-up
store his vinyl i don't [ __ ] know
what he's doing
i was very very close to opening up a
pop-up record store
i found a record distributor down in
florida i found a guy that makes
turntables i found a speaker company
i had it all going on and then uh at the
last second i was like you know mary was
gonna run it i'm like
i don't know it just seemed like a lot
of i i don't know what i mean though you
see what i mean when i why i get
irritated when i hear this [ __ ]
don't you think producing the howard
stern show would keep you
so busy that couldn't even think
straight gary says quote i was
contacting vendors yeah i spoke with the
record guy who does the wrap-up show
that was literally the vendor i
contacted
there's a guy who does a wrap-up show on
record store danny goes yeah i can get
your record i don't fantasize about
another job you know
i'm so [ __ ] busy with this one i've
turned down everything else
if someone said you you want to start a
vinyl professor you should say
even if it's your own brain telling you
saying hey you should start a vinyl
popular you should go
brain you're out of your mind well i did
get there in all fairness i did get
there just took me a little longer than
you did
i got there believe me i'm going to take
you so long i would never open up a
vinyl shop because that would only get
in the way of my napping
i want to call like the executive
producer of the jimmy fallon tonight
show or
the executive producer of jimmy kimmel's
show and it's excuse me
about their side businesses yeah do you
guys have side business why don't you
i mean that's all right i know you don't
it wasn't and i thought about it i gave
it something how many
how many how how many hours a day would
you think you would have worked at the
record store i wouldn't work there at
all i would have farmed it out
i was going to have mary run it that was
the whole point i was going oh i wasn't
going to work there at all that's monkey
mary
what i do with the howard stern show i
delegate by the way de la bate is
italian for delegate
what did you need to do to break even
did you figure all that out get your
meatloaf album
half off i literally didn't i mean i got
far enough but i didn't get far enough
to like you know i didn't
find a space or i didn't you know figure
out how much it was gonna how much i was
going to make or anything it just seemed
like a fun idea until it wasn't
yeah by stephen asia get a caja google
free
[Laughter]
i didn't tell you this so stephen
colbert's executive producer just opened
up a pop-up store
i think he sells yo-yos